hey what are you doing Friday yeah that
sounds great
I will definitely try to make it no I
don't think this weekend's going to work
yeah actually the whole month is kind of
booked maybe we could do something next
month but then next month we get into
the holidays what do you want to do oh
my god I am so sorry I can't make it
you've just just don't just stop being
my friend just not friends with me
anymore yeah Megan night on Friday works
for me
night on Friday works for me
yeah we could go to a movie or you could
just come to my place and we could watch
Netflix it's fine
making me schedule I mean I had the
cancel like three other things to do
this but it's fine I understand we could
stay home and watch the same movie and
text each other about it
will there be guys there let's get some
Mexican food wait let's go to Mexico now
okay so let's get there at 6:15 it's got
to be 6:15 because if it's later than
that we're gonna miss getting the seats
on the left and last time we got the
seats on the right it wasn't any good so
we really need to get those seats on the
left make sure wants together perfect
sounds great now I did get her texts